do you know that coffee is the second
most traded commodity in the world
surpassed only by crude oil due to its
widespread use and addictive nature
coffee was even banned in the 16th
century by some religious leaders they
deemed coffee as a bitter invention of
Satan and tried to prohibit its
consumption however these attempts were
largely unsuccessful and coffee
continued to gain popularity worldwide
some of the major benefits associated
with coffee include enhancing your
memory and lowering the risk of
developing diabetes Alzheimer's disease
and liver cancer
nevertheless depending upon how you
consume your coffee there are some
unique benefits
there are thousands of ways coffee is
prepared in different parts of the world
but the two most common ones are black
coffee and milk coffee
in this video we will take a look at how
black coffee differs from milk coffee
chemically and which type of coffee is
healthier in the end we will also talk
about which type of coffee you should
drink and avoid in certain situations
before we jump into the comparison let's
talk about the key players here dark
coffee also known as black coffee is a
classic option enjoyed by many for its
rich flavors and bold taste on the other
hand milk coffee is a combination of
coffee and milk offering a creamy and
milder experience
dark coffee is known for its Simplicity
it's just coffee beans brewed with hot
water without any additives it contains
very few calories zero fat and has
virtually no sugar it's also packed with
antioxidants and can potentially boost
your metabolism scientifically it is the
milk proteins that merge with coffee
globules to give rise to the signature
taste that characterizes lattes and
cappuccinos researchers at Nestle
Research Center in Switzerland conducted
a study to investigate the effects of
milk and non-dairy creamer on the
availability of polyphenols which are
the main type of antioxidants found in
coffee after giving healthy adults
various types of coffee including black
coffee and coffee with milk blood
samples were taken to measure the
bioavailability of polyphenols or the
level of polyphenols in the blood the
study found out that adding milk to
Coffee delayed the absorption of
polyphenols from gut but did not impact
the overall amount that was delivered to
the blood This research concluded that
polyphenols are eventually absorbed
completely from the gut regardless of
whether coffee is consumed with or
without milk
so the question is which coffee is
healthy and which one should you drink
since almost majority of the health
benefits of coffee come from polyphenols
it contains both milk coffee and black
coffee are healthy if consumed in
moderation and ultimately it comes to
your taste preference however there are
certain situations where you should
avoid black coffee and certain
situations where you should avoid milk
coffee let's talk about a few of them
if you want to lose weight and you are
following a weight loss program
consuming black coffee will help you
achieve your goal black coffee has
significantly lower calories as compared
to coffee with milk 1 cup of black
coffee has less than 5 calories in
contrast coffee that contains sugar and
milk has an astounding 56.6 calories per
cup
black coffee also boosts your metabolism
which is a key when trying to lose
weight
consuming pure black coffee energizes
you giving you much more mental
awareness and Clarity since there is no
cream or milk to limit its absorption
but drinking a cup of black coffee in
the evening may end up keeping you awake
for a long time late into the night for
those who have difficulty sleeping at
night experts recommend not having any
coffee whether black or with milk
especially after Sunset but if you are
planning to do something important in
the evening and you start to feel sleepy
taking coffee with milk would be the
healthier option and will keep you from
disturbing your sleep patterns
always remember the key to consuming
coffee in a healthy way and enjoy its
benefits is to drink coffee in
moderation limit your coffee intake to
less than 5 cups a day also you should
never drink coffee first thing in the
morning especially on an empty stomach
I am a major coffee lover myself and I
used to drink coffee all the time
probably more than 10 cups a day but
since a few years I started noticing the
side effects of consuming too much
coffee now I consume coffee in
moderation and that helps mean a lot of
ways
in our upcoming videos we will talk in
detail about the side effects of
excessive coffee consumption so make
sure to subscribe to our Channel if you
want to be notified about that video
what has been your experience with
drinking too much coffee I also want you
to write in the comment section below
whether you like black coffee or coffee
with milk and why
thank you so much for watching this
video I hope you liked it if you did
make sure to hit the like button and
subscribe to our channel for the
upcoming videos take care and stay
healthy